>From everything that we have said so
far, the technologies that are used to
enable computer cloud offerings must
address a number of requirements.
Clouds must provide fungible resources
which means that the resources can
easily be repurposed to
support different customers.
Potentially even with different
types of requirements.
Otherwise if cloud providers
have to allocate and
maintain physical resources for every
one of their customers, and the exact
same type of physical resources as
what the customers at least think they
require, then the economic opportunity
for cloud computing just won't be there.
This fungibility is
also necessary to deal
with some of the V that exists
within the cloud resources.
And we have different
generation of servers,
maybe even different types of servers.
And you don't really want the users
to have to deal with that.
You don't want them to be exposed
to the level of heteroingenuity.
Clouds must integrate resource
management methods that support
the premise of cloud computing so
they must be able to dynamically adjust
the resources that are allocated
to cloud users pending underneath.
So this needs to be done very flexibly,
very elastically.
Such management methods must be able
to operate at very large scales
of thousands and
tens of thousands of nodes.
The scale is important, both from
the perspective of the cloud provider.
So how many resources
it needs to manage.
But also from the perspective
of the customers.
Customers often look at clouds for
their resource needs because otherwise
they don't have access to
sufficiently large resource pools.
So then clouds must be able to provide
to potential customers the ability
to allocate really large collections
of resources for your individual needs
to the scalabilities required with
respect to that dimension as well.
Once scale is introduced,
failure has become inevitable, really.
If we have some probability that one
component in the system will fail,
the more such components
we put together,
the greater the probability that
something in that collection will fail.
So we have to incorporate
mechanisms to deal with failures.
Clouds, by definition,, are shared
resources across multiple tenants, so
cloud management has to deal
with this multi-tenancy,
has to provide mechanisms that
guarantee performance and
provide isolation across multiple
workloads, multiple tenants.
We cannot have one misbehaving tenant
that will somehow take control over all
of the resources and punish and hurt the
performance of the remaining tenants.
And finally an important concern
that must be addressed is
isolation of the state that's
being accessed in cloud systems.
With this respect,
clouds need to make guarantees regarding
the privacy of their tenants' data and
the security of the execution
environment that the cloud guarantees.
Another aspect of security's also
to make sure that their privacy and
security guarantees,
not just across tenants, but
also that the cloud provider
isn't going to somehow access or
take advantage of the state that
is managed by individual tenants.
And then also the other way around, that
the cloud computing player is protected
from certain vulnerabilities that
exist within a single tenant.
And therefore,
that one tenant isn't going to
affect the entire cloud platform.